[yelps]
Understanding
of the human mind
isn't complete unless it
considers everything
the brain is capable of.
♪♪
When is it okay to risk harm
in the name of science?
♪♪
I'm about to find out.
I'm a little anxious about
what's about to happen.
This will probably be
a little bit uncomfortable.
And my job?
I'm the lab rat.
I'm about to head up
the Amazon to drink
an ancient psychedelic drug.
I would suggest that
you think about
an emotional intention.
To make it emotional
is a lot more frightening
to me.
♪♪
I started to see
my body disappearing.
♪♪
There was no going back.
You're forced to see
the world differently,
and by seeing the world
differently,
it makes you think
differently.
What I wanna know is,
if we put them
in front of a switch,
watching a train barrelling
towards people,
would they actually
pull it?
I bet a lot of them
would freeze in that moment.
♪♪
This isn't about
having fun.
It's for science.
♪♪
I hope.
[all gasping]
♪♪